sad I wonder what I would do for my son
like if we had a salon and he was just
you know I was 15 and you're like like
babe he's not a cute kid and it's gonna
be a while before he gets laid I wonder
what we would offer him it's not dad
nothing to do with cute I was cute as
[ __ ] I mean not no no no you left listen
I was cute as [ __ ] the thing is this is
that in the 80s right I'm sorry but
being Asian wasn't sexy in the 80s now
these young kids they come to my show
I see like fancy Asian dudes right with
like slick hair undercard yeah an
undercut with like hot white chicks and
I'm like I did the groundwork where's my
respect residuals you know I'm the one
that you know me me and my kind pave the
[ __ ] road for you okay where's my
[ __ ] ding dong I'm just I would still
ask you though what if our kids new
concept what words
what if our kid was ugly even by our
standards and we hardly think anyone's
ugly I put my brother and I will take
him to Adelita at 15 yeah no that's what
I do not never allow you to take myself
to oh you can hooker I wouldn't tell you
yes you would what if he gets you
contracts like something they wear later
papa Bob oh yeah I trust them don't I
yeah we'll get our own condoms I'll
figure it out home but also couldn't we
just say sweetie you were still 15 like
many guys don't get laid well maybe I'll
just go ahead here's my old Jay account
also I'm pretty sure it's your child a
child with a personality I would soon
kind of person like outgoing extrovert
Joker I don't know that kid is gonna be
like be good it'd be our kids gonna be
confident so I'm saying I'm one both of
you how because the reason why I was the
way I was is because my parents were
it's not even like check it out
my dad didn't even know who the beetle
if you go who's Tom
why he doesn't know he doesn't know
anything he doesn't look he's never seen
a movie in his life he is an immigrant
he doesn't know he just wants to work
yeah right so he does he barely speaks
English he's not cool
he's know anything about pop culture or
anything my mom doesn't either and then
they also speak Korean at home they're
very traditional
you mean that died did the dead squids
hanging from the [ __ ] in the kitchen
that had to the drive with my friends
would walk into my house they're like
what is that smell that's what I live in
you know I mean like an Okinawan fish
market and you know it's like all those
little things
mm-hmm you know it it makes you kind of
go oh I'm weird I'm different you know
me and all that stuff it's only later in
life where I can buy my own clothes
right put my own Cologne on and just get
a sense of my own style where I was able
to do it but like our kids are gonna
have that our kids gonna be like oh my
god I know Gilbert what's your last name
Gohan come on he's a TV star by then
yeah you'll be a TV star by then and
then my kids my uncle I hope they don't
become entitled oh they are they're
going to be people no no not under my
watch yeah yeah they're gonna be humble
divine human being you guys live two
separate lives where you live in a small
house looking the burbs pretend you guys
are poor that you don't show any footage
that it's Bobby Lee from MADtv do you
guys have any celebrity they don't know
that dad you know on the weekends you
guys like okay we're gonna go we have to
work far away out of town you guys live
your normal lives it's just your kid is
raised I guess no no double life I think
that he's not like you know so big that
we might two years ago Adam from Okinawa
I mean I'm right yeah we're gonna fade
those suckers we'll do you know that's
like one of the biggest reasons people
start to resent each other
it's like conflicting parenting
[Music]